they're all on the run
going from house to house to try to keep
ahead of taliban fighters bent on
revenge
all of them worked for or were trained
by the foreigners who pulled out nearly
six months ago
many have letters of commendation and
pictures alongside their former foreign
friends
now they and their children are taliban
targets feeling abandoned by former
allies and hunted by those now in power
they left us behind and now we're not
safe so i ask the international
community to please help us either with
our security here or get us out of here
in this place she was shot yes while she
was traveling her mother was a soldier
in the afghan army gunned down a few
months ago the rest of the family are
terrified they're next
we are nervous about
for our security our family
we don't want to go another country or
any
good situation we want to
live in safe situation in our country
but this is not possible this is our
video the taliban has searched my home
they say the taliban promises of an
amnesty for those who worked with the
foreigners have come to nothing
among the group is the son of the female
head of harat's women's prison
his mother aliyah as easy disappeared
nearly four months ago and they've not
seen her since
[Music]
he breaks down telling us they think
she's being held by the taliban because
she's a woman and from the hazara ethnic
group
the meeting quickly splits up they're
all hazaras
and very anxious words will get out that
they're here
they head back into hiding
since the taliban took power thousands
of hazaras have fled half of those who
lived here have gone mostly over the
border to iran
one of the elders tells us the
persecution they felt for so long is far
worse under the taliban
when we go to government offices they
won't even talk to us
the challenge is making sure the aid
reaches those who need it and there are
concerns it's being misused by the
taliban
with most money frozen and aid halted by
the international community the new
taliban regime has been offering food
aid to workers in exchange for salaries
but that's led to claims that the aids
only going to taliban supporters
that's hit the hazara worst they've
always been anti-taliban and whilst the
un's trying to ensure aid goes through
groups they've approved
most hazara we spoke to feel the
discrimination
it's happening all over afghanistan she
says but the hazara of the poorest and
worst hit and the taliban don't like us
for the hazara the war is not
over this was the latest bombing less
than a week ago in the heart of the
hazard community
seven people were killed mostly women
isk said they did it for the hazaras the
attacks are coming from all sides
among the victims was a single mother
her five young children are now all
alone
they're terrified and helpless
there was no one to help my mother she
tells
and if anyone had helped she'd still be
alive
she's also angry at the lack of
everything here
there wasn't even an ambulance she goes
on they took them to hospital in private
cars
they're still in shock but they know
this means trying to find work in a land
that doesn't even recognize their right
to do that
my little sister cries all night until
morning she says asking where her mother
is she's very young and scared
female hazara and now orphans with no
one to look after them
alex crawford sky news in her at